hey guys welcome back to another video
and if you are wondering when the some
knows and that's the part where I did
all the seems rushed I do have to
apologize like I explained it in the
first video but I've explained it now in
the first video explained that my hard
drive crashed and it got corrupted and
everything mostly got lost in it so I'm
trying to regroup everything trying to
get the editing software trying to get
Photoshop trying to get everything back
to normal again so it'll take me a
couple days to get everything situated
so I'm going to be spending most of the
week on a weekend on so thank you all
for sticking around and not leaving but
anyway boys let's get right into this
video first off I want to give a shout
out to all the Vikings for winning the
faction war good fight boys I was a
knight and I was pretty upset that we
did get a tiebreaker and lose but anyway
GG boys so enjoy your new emblem outline
and all your new ornaments for all your
characters there are new executions I'm
going to release for every character
about 7000 feel each so go grab your
executions for each of your favorite
characters I do not have a video off of
these characters just yet as I said I'm
kind of working on getting everything
situated so like I said up to the
weekend everything should be fine anyway
continuing on the devs are are aware of
a random glitch where players will be
kicked automatically and immediately
joining a match there are still no
Raider buffs coming but they have said
that there is something that they didn't
want to put in this patched and didn't
really work out yet so there's no news
on it yet sadly oh you radar means now
you can now join games during the
character selection on the face off
screen so it makes more games full at
the beginning of the game rather than
halfway through ranked mode is coming
but they're only after they fix the
stability issues in connection of the
game I kind of make sense I'd rather not
be in a ranked game or winning and
losing matters and then get disconnected
and get a loss on top of that they're
also working the defensive metaphor
trying to figure out a system of not
being able to - ball out of stamina and
then also fixing carrying making it a
lot harder and probably shortening the
window a bit
lastly Ubisoft is giving all players
three day champion status on April 28th
which is today and also - as as the time
of making this video these servers are
out once again so maybe an extra three
days of champion status and maybe we'll
have six straight days and we'll have to
see the rest of the stream was basically
talking about the new characters and the
new gear coming to season 2 I did cover
that in last video because I was kind
rushing and I didn't know what to put in
what video and then I thought of I put
everything in one would be too long so
if you guys want to hear more about the
characters strictly it will be in last
video anyway guys thank you and that
like I said in the beginning and I said
in last video I did have issues of a
computer that's why I kind of post for
the week but everything is resolved now
we're going to be rolling going to be
figuring out everything that's why
hopefully everything will be up to par
by Monday if not a couple days after I
will be doing the Dead stream next week
on Thursday and then anything else that
comes up in between the week regarding
these characters anyway boys I hope you
all did enjoy and peace out guys have a
great rest of your day